[Musica]
ciao a tutti
ok iniziato
siete in tantissimi
allora quello che vedete le mie spalle
sono io e potrei presentarmi a voi
dicendovi che sono un viaggiatore
leggero un backpacker o un treno
in realtà quello che mi piace dirvi di
me e che sono una persona che ama lo
slow travel quindi il viaggiare
lentamente
nello specifico il viaggiare lentamente
e con la sola propria forza del corpo e
nel 2015 per la prima volta ho
sperimentato questo tipo di viaggio è
dapprima facendo uscite brevi magari di
un weekend o di una settimana e poi
andando via via a ad aumentare la
distanza e stando via anche per più
tempo così nell'arco di tre anni ho
percorso circa 12 mila e 200 chilometri
a piedi nei posti più disparati
tornando da un viaggio che avevo fatto
nel 2018 nei balcani
ero stato lì in in estate quindi
facciamo un caldo pazzesco
tornando da quel viaggio mi ero detto
che il prossimo viaggio avrei voluto
fare in un posto al fresco tipo nel nord
europa ma non sappiamo ancora né come né
dove né quando né verso dove se non che
è sempre in quel periodo lì quindi era
inverno del 2003 al 2018 al 2019
mentre ero a casa di un mio caro amico
qua di novara jack
stavano sistemando il suo garage mi
capita tra le mani questa bicicletta che
in realtà io avevo sempre visto lì però
non avevo mai pensato a niente però
quella mattina flash toccando questa
bici ho avuto l'idea di usarla per
partire di casa e andare su fino a capo
nord ovvero il punto più a nord
dell'europa per chi non lo sapesse va
beh noi siamo qua lo sapete capo nord
invece sta la impunta la norvegia e la
distanza che separa questi due punti è
di circa 5.000 km quindi insomma sarebbe
stato un viaggio un po complesso il più
complesso che avrei fatto fino a quel
momento e volevo farlo con una bici
appunto così
il mio amico mi lascia la bici la porta
da un altro mio amico a sistemarla
olivero e
iniziò a diffondere l'idea sui miei
canali social ampio anche un canale
youtube perché avrei voluto documentare
il viaggio attraverso dei blog apra
anche una campagna di clos funding per
raccogliere fondi per per il viaggio e
dopo
già pochi giorni inizia ad arrivare i
primi apprezzamenti persone che mi
incitavano che mi gasa vano ma
parallelamente a loro anche persone che
in qualche modo mi bocciavano un po
l'idea perché non avevo esperienza non
non avevo il fisico cioè mi vedete non è
che sia così atletico la bici che aveva
usato non era non era performante per
quel tipo di viaggio somma una serie di
problematiche che in realtà esistevano
perché effettivamente non avevo mai
fatto viaggio in bici era il viaggio più
lungo che avevo fatto fino a quel
momento la bce lavoro scelta a caso
però la cosa che mi dava coraggio e che
io arrivavo da uno stile di viaggio che
era veramente distruttivo che quello del
viaggiare a piedi perché il massimo che
puoi fare viaggiando a piedi almeno io
che riesco a fare quattro chilometri
orari
quindi camminando tutto il giorno dopo
che ti fai 30 chilometri di distanza sei
morto mentre con la bicicletta per
quanto casuale fosse avrei potuto per
coprire il doppio delle distanze sono
anche il triplo e far portare abc la la
bici molto più peso che non nel mio
zaino però perché avevo ricevuto queste
critiche insomma così per questa bici e
vorrei farvela vedere così almeno capite
anche un po in ogni attimo voi in sala
di cosa stiamo parlando
autentici moderno l'amico no no va bene
così marco polo metterla di taglio
si voi direte perché non hai messo il
cavalletto c'era il cavalletto ma si è
rotto
sì dai
e a lei e rosi
che è una simil graziella e si chiama
rosella realtà nasce realmente rosell
ottenuta tale perché mi sembrava giusto
così fatto sta che comunque parto con
con la mia graziella il 5 maggio del
ovviamente dopo i primi giorni c'era il
primo problema da affrontare del viaggio
ovvero superare le alpi
io avevo trovato un punto abbastanza
semplice che mi sembrava semplice per
superare le alpi che quello che vedete
qua dietro ovvero tra chiavenna e coira
c'è poi il confine tra italia e svizzera
lì e questo era il primo vero ostacolo
che mi era anche stato descritto da un
sacco di persone cioè non riuscirà a
superare le alpi effettivamente è un
casino superarle
però io non sarei riuscito a superarle
pedalando sulla bici c'è quello era
ovvio però la mia idea era quella di
superarle camminando tanto l'avevo fatto
fino un sacco di anni prima
e così dopo non mi ricordo se ai tre o
quattro giorni questo era il punto in
cui avevo poi superato le alpi la zona è
quella dopo un po di giorni riesco ad
arrivare su in punta loew le arpa schera
il punto più alto poi quando a superare
delle alpi cosa divertente parli vedete
con un guanto solo non perché lo avessi
perso ma perché è l'unico che c'è quello
che avevano avuto l'auto per strada
perché non pensavo di trovare la neve
che non c'è un freddo pazzesco e quindi
stavo con una mano in tasca l'altro
dopo dopo un paio di giorni capite già
il disagio che aleggiava nell'aria
niente alla fine poi ho superato anche
le alpi quindi sono uscito dall'italia
attraversato la svizzera tutta la
germania e finalmente sono poi arrivati
in danimarca
perché vi dico finalmente perché io
prima di partire mi hanno documentato un
po giustamente sul viaggio su chi
l'aveva fatto prima di me ci sono tanti
che lo fanno e leggendo le
da chi era passato poi dalla danimarca e
dalla norvegia tutti descrivevano alla
danimarca come un paese semplicissimo ad
attraversare perché effettivamente è
piatto non è una montagna di niente
mentre la norvegia era un paese molto
più impegnativo perché al contrario
della danimarca è un paese solo montuoso
i fatti poi vedete una cartina la
danimarca e verde vuol dire tutta
pianura la norvegia è una montagna unica
cosa divertente quando sono arrivati in
danimarca in realtà altro lato complessa
la danimarca
quindi per me la norvegia che già era un
mostro era diventata una cosa
insormontabile pazzesca cioè detto cosa
ci vado a fare in norvegia
così ho passato gli ultimi giorni in
danimarca
scervellarmi per capire di che morte
sarei dovuto morire passando dalla
norvegia
lascio il porto della danimarca tipo
condannato a morte e e alla fine arriva
in norvegia
da qua ero praticamente a metà del
viaggio altri 2.500 km sarebbero stati
in questo paese super montuoso super
montuoso ma anche super bello io mi sono
reso conto che era arrivato lì per mio
volere c arrivato per le mie forze
sudando salite non salite e questo mi ha
fatto vedere le montagne della norvegia
da una prospettiva totalmente diverso
ovvero si erano faticose ma era un modo
anche per vedere un paesaggio che io
sognavo di vedere che la con la
norvegese dei fior di queste pineti
immense e il primo giorno che io sono
partito da oslo sono partiti con la
giornata pazzesca un sole incredibile si
stava bene sembrava quasi estate c'erano
anche moschini purtroppo il primo giorno
quindi anziché partire con quest'ansia
incredibile dalla norvegia sono partito
gasatissimo e il giorno quel giorno lì
che son partito ho fatto il mio record
personale che va beh ancora oggi non so
riuscito a battere che è di 104 km con
quasi 1000 m di dislivello che qualche
ciclista in sala o che ascolta si farà
una risata però per me era tanto per la
dc tariq ha iscritto
grazie
e questo perché appunto avevo visto la
norvegia sotto un altro punto di vista
che era quello di esplorarla e vedeva il
più possibile percorro praticamente
tutta la norvegia quelle che vedete
evidenziati in verde sono le uniche
città in cui poi mi ero fermato
veramente a dormire in una struttura
perché per quanto mi sforzassi o di
vedere il mio budget che avevo messo da
parte come infinito in realtà non lo era
e quindi avrei dovuto tagliare fin da
subito sulle cose superflue perché la
norvegia un paese incredibilmente bello
ma incredibilmente costoso e tipo il
secondo il terzo paese più costoso al
mondo e quindi un sacco di cose avrei
dovuto toglierle partendo appunto dal
posto in cui sei andato dormire io ho
praticamente fatto tutto della norvegia
dormendo in tenda perché il modo
migliore per risparmiare un po di soldi
e anche vedersi il paesaggio che
incredibilmente bello e anche perché la
norvegia permette di farlo in modo
legale il campeggio libero
l'unico problema era il meteo perché
norvegia più di un sacco e il meteo
imprevedibile quindi molte volte mi
trovavo a dormire nei bivacchi casuali
che trovavo o abusivamente nel cortile
delle persone con i garage o nelle
chiese anche se ogni posto andava bene
ormai stessa cosa per il lavorare io
comunque mentre viaggiavo lavorava anche
i video che poi pubblicavo e ogni posto
era buono qua ero tipo in libreria ma
lavorava anche qua nelle chiese nei fast
food e super nei centri commerciali
dove capitava sui traghetti
altro problema era il caricare le
batterie banalmente anche solo quella
del telefono quindi ogni posto che
trovavo al chiuso andava bene anche
quello per cercare una presa di corrente
quindi mi mettevo a caricare le cose
anche qua in chiesa nei supermercati nei
fast food da che avevo bisogno di
corrente elettrica per le batterie
altro problema era quello di lavarsi non
avendo un posto fisso un bagno che mi
lavavo dove capitava nelle fontane o nei
simil autogrill dove dove trova un posto
con dell'acqua corrente
se fino a qua comunque vi ho descritto
un po dei modi per risparmiare soldi io
mi ero inventato anche un modo
praticamente mai avevo scoperto un modo
per guadagnare anche qualche soldo
chiara e l'altra un metodo molto
semplice perché funziona così nel nord
europa che è quello del smaltire le
lattine io non comprava le lattine male
recuperavo per strada mentre viaggiavo
con la bici quindi mi faceva i miei
sacchi con non so 2 3 buste piene di
lattine e poi andavo a smaltirla in
queste macchinette qua e loro in cambio
ti davano un uno scontrino in cui
convertivano il numero di latina che
avevi smaltito bottiglie in corone
norvegesi e tu potevi usarle e poi come
buono nel supermercato per comprarti poi
la spesa cosa che io facevo eni cucinavo
fuori dai supermercati
suscitando anche un po l'indignazione
delle persone questa era una clip che a
me faceva sempre ridere incredibile
cuore un po 4 vicino alle lofoten e ce
le persone lo so che il fibroma avessero
visto buon film horror che poi il
migliore è lui che arriva con la macchia
c'è lui proprio e rusty se n'è andato
via proprio schifo
grazie comunque guerra o sempre in mezzo
alle lofoten e un piccolo paese chiamato
balsa da e anche qua stavo facendo la
mia solita routine o facendo finta che
fosse casa mia il piazzale lì fuori
se non che però attorno a me non c'erano
persone abbastanza indignate ma dei
ragazzini super incuriositi che sono
quelli là dietro che un attimo dopo me
li sono ritrovati tutti al tavolo perché
loro mi avevano visto con la gopro in
mano mentre filmava e avevano capito che
fossero youtube ero comunque una persona
che stava facendo video e anche siccome
anche loro lo erano si sono gasati
tantissimo e sono venuti al tavolo con
me e ho passato una giornata fantastica
quel giorno lì perché io neanche ci
volevo andare a bastad però andare lì
conoscendo questi ragazzi quali ho avuto
modo di vedere uno spaccato di vita che
era il loro che la tipo lì eravamo
andati a fare il bagno nel lago dove
loro vanno dopo la scuola mi avevano
portato in barca perché un villaggio di
pescatori e quindi tutti hanno la barca
ed è stato incredibile quel giorno
forse uno dei più belli di tutto il
viaggio ma a questo punto voi vi
chiederete qual è il giorno più bello
poi di tutto il viaggio e
posso darvi una pre risposta e poi una
posta risposta la pre risposta è che
alla fine dopo 119 giorni
prova ricordandole
4.678 km sono arrivato da capo nord che
questo globo qua
e
voi penserete perché anch'io lo pensavo
che il giorno più bello sarebbe stato
quello dell'arrivo fate conto che un ora
prima diluvia lo quando sono arrivato io
si sono aperte le nuvole sembrava
proprio un apparizione divina ed è stato
quello in realtà il giorno più bello
fino a quel momento perché ero arrivato
a completare il mio obiettivo però la
cosa interessante è che molte volte
quando ci poniamo l'obiettivo e lo
raggiungiamo non sappiamo quali sono le
altre cose collegate al raggiungimento
di quell'obiettivo nel mio caso non
avevo minimamente idea che il giorno più
bello sarebbe stato il giorno dopo
quello dell'essere arrivato a capo nord
perché fuori da ogni previsione perché
era il primo settembre quella sera
apparsa l'aurora boreale e per la prima
volta nella mia vita ho avuto il piacere
di vederla ed è stato incredibile perché
non me l'aspettavo minimamente in
conclusione perché vi ho parlato fino
adesso dio che viaggio con la grazia e
la raccolgo lattine
perché
perché i viaggi specialmente fatto in
questo modo qua sono capaci di
insegnarti tantissimo e regalarvi una
marea di emozioni storie persone che
incontri i luoghi ma quando ripensa
questo viaggio qua c'è una cosa che
salta subito alla mia mente ed è
quella che
questo viaggio mi ha insegnato è che noi
possiamo anche cambiare il nostro punto
di vista ma non cambieremo la natura
delle cose io potevo anche fare finta
che questa bici fosse la bici perfetta
per il cicloturismo che fosse in
carbonio
realtà rimane sempre una graziella avrei
potuto pensare che le alpi fossero state
semplici che la norvegia una landa
piatta ma non sarebbero cambiate le cose
il cambiare punto di vista non cambia la
natura delle cose
ma cambia la percezione che noi ne
abbiamo
grazie
ne vado
[Applauso]